sometimes I'm asked about how to resolve
relationship conflict and I find this
amusing and I'm smiling because this has
never been a strong suit for me as it
relates to intimate relationships I am
NOT famous for my patience and have
caused innumerable problems in my
relationships as a result of that and
grew up at least through schooling and
coaching with very little positive
reinforcement a lot of negative
reinforcement which also doesn't help
matters but I have found a few different
approaches and frameworks perhaps tools
also that have helped me greatly
personally to be a better partner to my
girlfriend for instance and also tools
that help us together as a couple to
resolve conflict it's not about avoiding
conflict I think that there's a certain
amount of conflict that can be avoided
but whenever you are spending 24/7
together or in close proximity you're
going to have friction in the system and
that is certainly true with even my
closest maybe especially my closest guy
friends but let's talk about the tools
first I believe that to minimize
conflict or quickly resolve conflict you
need to first become more aware of your
internal States and become more aware of
the stories that you create in your head
the loops that you play that will inform
how you interact with someone else
because if for instance you create a
story where you were always the victim
and that is your pattern that will
greatly affect how you approach any type
of conflict resolution or discussion and
two tools I found very very helpful for
that on number one sam harris is waking
up up i highly recommend getting it i
have no skin in the game no equity no
payoff and hook kickbacks nothing so sam
harris is waking up app which provides a
logical progression of skill development
in meditation or really self-awareness
that's number one it gives you a 10
minute practice each day that i do in
the mornings i still use this app i've
run
multiple times it's exceptional that
pairs very well with a book called
awareness and for some reason it has
multiple subtitles depending on the
format one of them is I believe the
promises and perils of reality the other
is conversations with the masters but
that doesn't make any sense because
there's really only one author and that
is Anthony de Mello so the book title is
awareness the author Anthony de Mello de
mal o who was a Jesuit priest and also a
psychotherapist very interesting
combination and that book will also help
you to recognize the stories the movies
you're creating as an interpretation of
events it will also help you to become
very bluntly honest with yourself in a
self-assessment so that you are able to
spot where you genuinely want to fix
problems or where you are more wedded to
drama perhaps and those two tools
combined especially have been incredibly
valuable for me and that's kind of step
one my girlfriend has also gone through
both of these and it's helped us to
pause because between the stimulus and
your response there is a gap and in the
gap is where everything can change
that's where you get to choose your
response to be a response able okay
so step number one is really working on
yourself to be a better partner then as
a couple I think having a very candid
assessment of your sensitivities and pet
peeves is very important for instance my
girlfriend at some point this was maybe
six months ago nine months ago asked me
about wordsmithing she wanted to know
how she could craft feedback in the
perfect way she didn't phrase it that
way but in a better way such that I
would be more receptive to certain types
of feedback and we were doing a
quarterly couples work which I also
recommend so having sometimes
facilitator like a therapist at least
once a quarter to a
assist with a couples day that we block
out we do this once a quarter and during
one of those sessions I said it's not
about the content it's about the timing
and I think this is true for a lot of
couples rather than having things
piecemeal throughout the day it is
helpful for some of us especially
someone like me who is wedded to
structure and predictability as much as
possible you might not think that might
not expect that but it's true on a daily
basis I thrive with structure and I said
it doesn't matter what the word smithing
is you could be you could be Tolstoy you
could be Nabokov it doesn't matter I I
need things to be timed in a particular
way that would be my preference and so
we set aside on a say weekly or
bi-weekly basis a batching session and
the batching session allows us to
discuss what it is that we need what it
is that's bothering us and the framework
or I should say the format we've used
and I'm not aware of any reading we've
done that has informed this way it was
trial and error is we first talk about
what the other person is doing well what
we love what we'd love more of right now
what we love more of is gonna come again
but what the other person what our
partners doing well then we talk about
what we think we're doing well
personally and then we talk about what
we would like even more of okay rather
than saying what you're [ __ ] up what
you're screwing up what's driving me
crazy it's like you know what I would
really enjoy more of what would really
make me happy to get more of his ex and
that type of very simple format has
worked for us and it is recorded not
necessarily audio recorded but the the
takeaways the homework assignments are
recorded if you do something like
Evernote you could use notes so that
there's follow-up without follow-up this
is all pissin in the wind so you need
follow-up so there are then the meeting
notes so to speak from this batching
session and we each get a copy and this
way we can do two things we can refer
back to it so that for the neck
at least several days following that
back just batching session refer to that
say in the mornings as a reminder and
then when we do our next batching
session we can see how we've done we can
look at the at the assignment and then
the report card and sometimes I'll fall
short and I'll beg God you know I
supposed to do that I totally blind him
so sorry there's an accountability that
is really important all right so we've
talked about a couple things so far we
talked about waking up at Sam Harris we
talked about awareness Anthony de Mello
we've talked about batching sessions and
I also mentioned in passing these
quarterly couples and days it's an
entire day set aside let's just call it
from like 10 a.m. to 8 p.m. something
like that to talk and to have some type
of facilitation and it can be very
freeform in this case there's less
structure and it's really just talking
about whatever's on our mind
whatever our wants our are our needs
being met our things bothering us are
our desires payment whatever it might be
and for me at least these tools and
having this type of structure has been
invaluable and last but not least as my
friend of all raava Khan
one of the best investors and
entrepreneurs I know has said and I'm
gonna paraphrase if you want to avoid
conflict step number one is do not
associate with people who are always in
conflict right so choose your friends
choose your partners very wisely you
were gonna be the average of the five
people you associate with most so choose
wisely
good luck
you